throughout the millennia forest fires
have been sweeping regularly through the
savanna of the Sahara in the heart of
Brazil but now that the land is formed
the fires have become too commonplace
this unique natural habitat is at risk
as part of a fire management scheme fire
brigades help local farmers contain the
fires on well d oliveira and his
colleagues are kept very busy and the
job is back-breaking hey buddy yeah it
depends on what time of year the fires
begin and whether it's rained much if it
hasn't rained a lot there are more fires
on average we see 250 to 280 fires per
season did you lose in Samantha's
instance we think the folks slash and
burn practices have already destroyed
more than half of the sahaja a region
that's home to unique flora and fauna in
Mateos a town in the middle of the
protected area of jalapa they're setting
up a firefighting centre it's funded by
the international climate initiative an
observation satellite is now in use in
the area it helps identify whether it's
better to tackle a fire or let it run
its course usually an inspection of the
area is done by plane the protected area
of jalapa alone is as big as Switzerland
large fires are usually caused by heat
or lightning and they're impossible to
contain they're too far away for the
firefighters to deal with
controversially farmers Yvonne and Minh
allow have long relied on traditional
slash and burn agriculture even though
the technique used to be banned in the
protected area it's a no-go figure your
father if we're not allowed to use our
traditional techniques then we can't
maintain the quality of our produce and
we also end up producing less bloom in
the practice is once again legal so long
as the fire brigade is on hand the
carbon dioxide in the ash makes the soil
more fertile and land is cleared for new
crops the fire management program is
designed to help Brazil reduce its
carbon
site emissions by nearly forty percent
by 2020 sometimes the program cease fire
fighters start fires deliberately as
Philip was from the German agency for
international cooperation explains this
can be beneficial for the environment
the GI z-coordinates the german aid
program in the sahara and advises the
brazilian government before ethelyn
improving forest fire prevention in the
brazilian savannah in the sahara plays
an important role in protecting the
areas carbon storage function and
reducing greenhouse gas emissions it's a
key contribution to international
climate protection by talk them into
nuts nike muffler conserving nature by
burning it it's a new approach in Brazil
but reducing the entire country's carbon
emissions would entail introducing the
strategies practiced in the jalapao
protected area across the whole of the
sahaja